you didn't go into a major depression
when rage broke up like you didn't sit
there and now what we did what we did
when rage broke up was we went over to
rick rubin's house
tim and brad and i were like we what are
we gonna do
and we listened to bad motor finger by
sound garden
a lot and we said maybe we should talk
to that dude
i don't know what a voice what a voice
but i'll tell you it was it was
it was an interesting it was an
interesting beginning because
while um particularly like the song
slaves and bulldozers
[Music]
was hugely influential on me and i think
that soundgarden chris cornell in
particular
helped redeem hard rock music in that
fans like me who i love big riffs i
loved heavy riff rock music
but a lot of times i could not relate to
the lyrics which were either about the
devil or groupies neither of which
were significant to me yeah but
soundgarden
along with a couple of other bands like
chris was smart and you could tell
and he was poetic and he had like this
kind of dark
poetry that connected on a level that
felt yeah but he
he also unapologetically embraced the
big riff rock so anyway
so rick and i decided we're gonna go
talk to chris and see what he thinks so
chris lives on the last loneliest
castle in ojai like it's an hour and a
half outside of l.a
and rick rubin like at the time i'm
driving still
being punk rock i'm driving my 1985
chevrolet astro van
and now rick doesn't leave the house
unless he's in a rolls royce that's in
another rolls royce
so he's serious about he must be serious
about this because he gets in my van to
go
so we drive up there and the one thing
about chris's vocals and his lyrics that
there's a
there's a spookiness to them and there's
a sort of a a darker side to them
and so i don't really know what he's
going to be like so we drive up there
and he and we're you know it's
in the darkening it's dusk and we're
kind of these tree-lined
transylvanian-like streets and we get up
to the top and there's chris's
kind of spooky mansion there's some
motorcycles out front and there's like
the long sort of
traipsing staircase and rick and i pull
up and
and the doors you know the doors open
straight up
adam's family style like with nobody
opening the doors
and here comes chris six to a frame dark
of countenance
and he comes kind of slowly loping you
know down the steps and rick turns me
and goes
let's get the [ __ ] out of here like our
souls are in peril
uh unfortunately we did not it was scary
it was
we it was weird it was like it was weird
yeah it was like hey guys
hey guys come on in you know you know
have a cider
um but fortunately we did we did
persevere and
uh and i was in you know a band uh you
know those those three audio slave
records and
while chris was a friend and while chris
was a band mate i never stopped being a
fan of his
and his ability to craft melody out of
the ether
you could throw it with whether it was a
you know a few
simple chords like the song like a stone
or whether it was some complicated
you know heavy riff he would
effortlessly create something that was
either beautiful or terrifying
and is there an adjustment for you as a
guitar player that all of a sudden
you're working with a new guy
yes absolutely i mean not so much not so
much working with a new guy but working
with like a melodic singer
you know and his strengths were with
melody and it really
challenged and pushed tim and brad and i
you know like the music of rage against
the machine is james brown bass it all
comes around to the one
you know it's like it's the same driving
beat in the same driving rhythm that
comes around because it's rapping and
it's it's like the
excellent punk rock vocals of zach with
chris in order to allow him to shine
there had to be this kind of harmonic
counterpoint so it really you know like
that song like a stone was
you know it's a few simple chords but
allows chris's beautiful voice to soar
you